[Music]
2005 draft night we have our board it's
up on the wall if people see me on the
board you know see me showing the board
here so first round grazes every team
yeah you know we have at that time we
had maybe 20 players above a first-round
line okay
so 30 didn't have 32 we had 20 20 people
you think were the first round pick 24
was our pick 24 so two things happen
that night number one everyone we wanted
except one player got taken that's right
we wanted to Marcus we're bad Dallas we
wanted mark his Spears bad Dallas we
wanted learned the guy on ESPN my friend
[ __ ] oh yeah Cincinnati we wanted
Derek Johnson Kansas City we wanted we
want a pac-man Tennessee so the second
thing that happened we did yeah we never
issues there the second thing that
happened was no one was taken the
quarterback Aaron Rodgers now Gruden had
told him he's gonna take him to his face
Jordan takes Cadillac Williams okay
Tennessee we thought they're taking him
no they took pac-man Kansas City we
thought no they took Derek Johnson we're
coming up on this and now Gary you got a
picture this I'm in the middle
we got management Ted on the left with
Mike I'm sorry Mike Sherman not McCarthy
yeah is over here and all these
offensive coaches and stuff over here
we're about to sort of get up to our
spot and these offensive coaches are
yanking and they're like Andrew we can't
do this can't take this because we don't
need a bright Mars in place right we've
got other needs if you're a coach and
who do they want and who do they want
last thing you want as a coach is taking
a player in the first round that will
not play over years not help you this
year not help you next year maybe not
help you ever so they want us to dip
into our second round grades and take I
don't offensive line on a receiver or
even the defensive coaches take he's a
he's our only player up there in the
first round great
and II it was 50/50 that he was gonna go
number one right so San Francisco takes
no and he drops so now we got all the
management and it's real quick real
quick cuz I like breaking up the story a
little quick gut feeling do you think
Aaron Rodgers has as successful a career
if he goes one overall no you don't you
do believe that that [ __ ] like you knew
you think he would be good but you do
believe that something happened in that
hour that ship on the show a couple
hours that chip on the shoulder was a
tremendous fuel for more success yeah
and I think backing up Brett helped he
hated it but I think it helped rather
than being thrown into whatever I seen
on so not insurances which is a great
question which is sitting behind far for
three years
yeah did it help separate question right
chip on shoulder yeah I think so cuz he
plays them well shitty trades on that
and he's good at trading on the radio I
get to but bring me 200 decent I always
told Aaron Braden just 200 you're 24 I
mean how many players would have been
one I know
[ __ ] finishing up that story they say
what do we always say now these GM's are
now all GM's Reggie McKenzie Jake the
best player in the board right uh-huh
what does doesn't matter tick if the
Jets do that this [ __ ] we don't need
more defense Jets about listening good
Russ the board so here's here's the
story Ted Thompson says get him on the
phone I thought he meant him in the
agent Mike Sullivan who I've known
forever I call the number hello Mike
Mike's the agents name
no it's Aaron Aaron it's Andrew Brown
from Green Bay Packers can I took the
mic and I felt so bad and then Aaron's
you know Mike's like are you gonna trick
him into taking me to I'm like hold on
so my instructions are 15 minutes then
yeah and Aaron's in this room that
caters have packed up everything he's
been there five hours yeah he's supposed
to go one it's 23 the cameras they
changed the rule after that yeah the
whole time and he's getting more pissed
the whole world's watching and you just
slip in so I gotta keep him there 12
more minutes said keep him on the phone
12 minutes
and let's see if that phone rings
because you guys had decided yeah you
got it somebody called you not any offer
but if we got a good offer a decent a
decent offer the whole NFL would look
different that phone 12 minutes you got
I'm watching Aaron I'm watching Mike
talk to me on the Flyers real quick for
everybody who's not a football nerd at
24 all those teams in the first round
that were heavily considering him but
for some reason when elsewhere they
couldn't have cost him a fortune
they could have used a second-round pick
and some other collateral it wouldn't
have been I don't know maybe second and
thirty maybe two twos to choose the
third to move back into the first round
take who they wanted at nine pac-man
Tennessee could have had it I mean they
McNair I'm trying to remember that it's
hard to remember but it wasn't so it
wasn't like you the fourth pick where
it's like you're giving up two drafts to
get one guy it wasn't hard to go into 24
oh my god from the early second-round
have-your-cake- and-eat-it-too and take
Aaron [ __ ] Rodgers but nobody called
crickets and you guys said [ __ ] it we'll
just take them two minutes left on the
clock ted says tell him I tell him and
you're like on the phone with them
bullshitting for 10 minutes yeah oh no
I'm not saying a word I'm not saying a
word cuz I don't want it you don't [ __ ]
I don't want to hear it I'm like Mike he
just got ahold you gotta stay with me
here long as twelve minutes Aaron's life
I'm sure and the way you say Aaron
congratulations
with the 24th selection in the 2005 NFL
Draft the Green Bay Packers select Aaron
Rodgers I immediately get a call from
Favre agent immediately immediately
Favre I'm sure Mike Favre talked to the
coast that buzzcut bus cook and then we
have a draft party listen to this we
have a draft party going on in Lambeau I
don't know a thousand people right below
us
yeah boo oh my god were they booing and
I'm like come on guys I'm like
everyone's buzzed saying yelling his ass
off he's like what the [ __ ] going on
yeah why are you doing that yeah like
what are you doing replacing him what
I'm like just hold on just hold on and I
had that conversation over three years
like you know you had two parties if you
were in the middle like for three years
bus at Brett's side is like are you just
trying to replace us no Aaron side is
doing us he's never gonna play what do
you train us did they did they ever
really pushed for Trejo never not in
those terms
no but they alluded to it I heard the
phrase he's never gonna retire many
times like we're right well how'd it did
it well I mean for years we asked Brett
to come back in that last year we
frankly didn't we didn't say don't come
back but we said it's up to you yeah he
didn't like the way you phrased I guess
and he now he retired a big teary press
conference in hindsight in hindsight
Mark Murphy or someone should have had
the conversation which is we think you
might want to come back at some point
you might get that itch and we're
letting you know we're turning the keys
over here because when he did come back
I was in that room I heard that
conversation where Mike McCarthy said
those three words we've moved on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
reset Starks
they are going to bring pressure again
Rodgers is going to roll
[Applause]
says a prayer
[Applause]
[Music]
it's insane
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]